[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec cette
semaine un invité exceptionnel visco
peines bonjour bonjour je pense que tout
le monde vous connaît vous êtes
paléontologues c'est votre métier c'est
votre passion
vous êtes sans doute le plus célèbre
paléontologue de la planète on va le
voir je crois vous avez fait une
quarantaine de livres qui sont vendus
dans le monde entier qui raconte
finalement l'avis des premiers hommes
vous donner des clés pour comprendre
d'où on vient c'est ça votre motivation
c'est sale le but de la paléontologie
forcément avec la paléontologie
sotra et sa fonction c'est d'étudier
tout ce qui a été la vie avant avant
aujourd'hui la vie passée or cette vie
passée elle a quand même 4 milliards
d'années autrement dit d'être notre
boulot c'est d'étudier tous les restes
de tous les animaux végétaux et
bactéries et virus
des
4 derniers milliards
d'années donc c'est un gros travail
alors on voit défiler tout tout vous
tous vos bouquins tout ce que vous avez
fait à l'origine de l'homme le singe
l'afrique l'homme mais en fait pour le
grand public la célébrité que vous avez
acquis vous la devez à vos travaux bien
sûr sur la connaissance de la
préhistoire mais aussi sur la découverte
j'allais dire du premier homme du
premier homme sur terre mais le premier
homme sur terre c'était une femme que
vous avez découvert cette fameuse l'uci
oui mais vous avez juste une parenthèse
aujourd'hui c'est vrai mais en 1961 j'ai
trouvé un premier restes fossiles
humains au tchad et j'étais devenu le
lob du tchad dans la presse et les
médias au moins un français et puis
ensuite au début de mes travaux en
ethiopie en 1967 avant lui si j'avais
trouvé des fossiles dans le sud de
l'ethiopie ce fossile humain aussi épris
humains dans la vallée de l'omo aux
émaux et j'étais devenu l'homme de l'omo
ça se retrouve aussi dans toute la
presse de l'époque et lucie à la russie
a
à tous vas tu a tout envahi oui
absolument vous êtes tombé amoureux de
l'uci ben c'était la starlette de la
savane c'était une petite une petite
bonne femme 1 m 10 exotiques fille
femelle un incontestable
origines à l'origine de l'humanité est
possible probable mais pas sûr mais ça
n'a pas d'importance elle est quand même
dans le vivier des ancêtres et tout ça
afin que les devenu une sorte de enfin
mieux qu'un qu'un symbole une icône de
corée mais qu'est ce qu'elle avait de si
extraordinaire en dehors d'être une
femme d'être la preuve c'est qu'elle
permet de dater l'origine non le le
goûter est extraordinaire c'est que on
n'avait jamais trouvé dans d'ancêtre de
cette époque plus de trois millions
d'années aussi complet alors je dirais
le moins incomplet coincer le moins
incomplet des ancêtres 50 dos bon alors
vous et moi nous avons 206 ossements et
du sis aussi avec 206 vous en avez
retrouvé
56-52 mais comme le corps est symétrique
quand on a un goût du mary histoire on
fabrique l'humérus gauche donc on la
reconstituer ce qui a été important
c'est que on a reconstitué la silhouette
est évidemment pour le public tout d'un
coup au lieu de voir trois bouts d'os
voir une silhouette savoir le l'être
vivant et et ça le rapproche autant dans
nos machines r je ne peut fonctionner ça
une femme debout alors je continue il ya
d'abord le côté qu'il y ait 50 2
ossements de côté que trois millions
deux cent mille ans à l'époque c'était
le maximum c'est un record
et aussi le fait que ça se sait fait
d'avoir laboratoire à paris le fait
qu'en étudiant les ossements on s'est
aperçu pour la première fois la toute
première fois en même temps c'est tout à
fait sûr que ses personnages étaient
debout redresser qu'ils étaient
redresser donc il était bipède comme
nous le sommes ou presque pas tout à
faire et mais qu en outre il continuait
à grimper dans le formidable pour un
paléontologue trouver des gens qui g
comme ceux d'avant et qui marche comme
ceux d'après
c'est la situation il a découvert
tidiane sy je puis dire et qu'on
n'attendait pas comme des seins qu'on
attendait pas du tout qu'on n'espérait
pas vous n'avez pas pensé du tout à ça
donc ça ça nous permet d'imaginer
comment il vivait monsieur un oui tout à
fait tout à fait
donc comment nous vivions autrefois
c'est ça mais ça et comme c'était un
milieu arboré avec un certain nombre de
darb d'ailleurs c'était une forêt plutôt
clair il est certain que au même titre
que nos cousins les chimpanzés elle
grimpait elles mangeaient des fruits
dans les arbres elle devait se faire des
dénis pour pour dormir ne serait ce que
pour éviter de se faire croquer par les
carnivores y en avait un certain nombre
puis on avait un certain nombre avec les
les grands de qualité supérieure l'an on
appelle les dents de sabre et
donc on la voit bien survivre
probablement dans une petite société une
petite société de 20 ou 30 personnes
quelques quelques familles et avec déjà
des enfants en danger la vie des enfants
sans doute oui on ne l'a pas vu d'après
le smi vous en avez retrouvé les enfants
amis oui oui oui se trouve que c'est
amusant d'ailleurs on a trouvé beaucoup
d'autres restent lucides un personnage
mais dans ce même site de hadda
retrouver brisés les tueries dans les
handicaps il assez ça on est en dedans
reste les typiques dans un grand désert
qui s'appelle la fin mai en outre j'ai
eu en effet un d'élèves qui s'appelle
lmc getz et les sénats et sept élèves
est venue à paris il a fait sa thèse à
paris il a fait sa thèse avec moi il est
retourné en ethiopie il a eu ce qu'on
appelle une concession c'est à dire que
détail copé lui a donné à certains
secteurs à à fouiller et dans ce secteur
qui a un peu plus de trois millions
d'années un million quatre cent mille
ans il a trouvé un enfant et c'est un
enfant de la même espèce sombre 10 et 1
c'est un petit de l'uci en probablement
en féminin aussi d'ailleurs mais les
symboles nazis dans une petite fille
encore vos jours aujourd'hui vous êtes
encore vous êtes professeur professeur
émérite au muséum national d'histoire
naturelle et au collège de france un
conseiller de voyager partout oui avec
les amis partout dans le monde entier
oui a bien sûr et forcément la
communauté des pannes autolog est pas
immense la communauté des gens qui
travaillent sur les restes humains est
encore plus réduite donc on connaît tout
le monde et quand on fait quand on fait
un colloque ont réuni des gens de
partout et ils sont très heureux de
venir de même que moi je suis heureux de
d'aller les rencontrer là où il se
trouve et c'est ça qui me fera ya pas de
querelles politiques n'a pas d'idéologie
l'idéologie ne s'est pas immiscé dans
vos fourneaux le le poids de la
recherche demeure très important je vois
ça à l'accalmie les sciences quand on
fait des élections il ya véritablement
ya peut-être des chapelles dans les
coulisses c'est possible mais mais dans
l'ensemble c'est vraiment le poids
scientifique du bonhomme
ceci dit il ya quand même une
compétition 1 la collaboration avec
quand même compétitive bien sûr c'est à
qui trouverait le plus ancien c'est
curieux c'est le plus ancien qui est
bien plus important que le plus récent
où il est là et lui si vous l'avez
découverte avec des confrères américains
on va peut-être retourner t3 vitrine
américains
et un français maurice taillables qui
d'ailleurs est mort il ya très peu très
peu de temps oui mais dans une autre
partie de votre vie vous avez travaillé
avec des russes ah oui oui je dois bien
oui je travaillais l'idée russe en
sibérie ouais dans le pays des dogmes à
notre don d'organes oui on a trouvé
beaucoup de mammouth ça va d'ailleurs
beaucoup surpris ça vous et moi j'avais
fouiller des dizaines d'années des
dizaines d'années en afrique est un peu
en asie et puis je me trouve là à
fouiller en sibérie donc j'avais trouvé
des os pendant très longtemps des
ossements et puis des denrées longtemps
et puis c'est tout et là je commence une
fouille à 250 km de la petite ville et
de cet endroit du timing et puis un beau
matin dans le trou que j'avais commencé
à creuser je trouve de l'espèce de des
troupes comme celle quelque chose de
bizarre des grands filaments je suis
étonné je râle jeu direct sur les
l'école des russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fondement de la
recherche et puis à force de tirer
dessus comme rien ne venait je me suis
aperçu que j'étais sur le dos sur le dos
d'un mammouth sur le dos d'un mammouth
congelé devant milan qui était là sous
mes pâtés et dans dans ce terrain qui
est à
-15° depuis des milliers d'années en
l'occurrence vingt mille années et donc
on l'a dégagée lui roberto piqueur ont
les moyens qu'il faut et puis on a
attendu deux mois se tait au mois de
juin on a attendu le mois de novembre
pour qu'ils fassent plus froid dehors
que dedans pour pouvoir le sortir et on
l'a extrait en d'hélicoptères pour
l'envoyer dans la petite ville
alors c'est extraordinaire quand on voit
ces grandes carcasses là c'est grand
c'est grand squelette de d'animaux des
mammouths les dinosaures qui font
aujourd'hui c'est la passion des enfants
en général 1 et oui dorsaz la question
qu'il pose souvent les enfants c'est
comment ils ont disparu les mammouths
est-ce qu'ils ont disparu au cours du
temps à la suite d'une évolution très
lente où est-ce qu'ils ont disparu
brutalement oui mais brutalement parfois
alors les mammouths ses dix mille ans 1
ouais les gars et 50 millions d'années
c'est tout à fait mais il concerne les
mammouths le fait de trouver comme je lé
fais comme je viens de vous le dire une
bête de vingt mille ans sous mes pieds
et dont la la chair était encore donc
ils ont 10 avril à 6 voilà il est arrivé
des moments des endroits des lieux et
des époques où la disparition a pu être
très rapide parce qu'autrement il serait
resté en surface les prédateurs
l'oreille au moins que you tu es un peu
or là les muscles de cette bestiole
d'anjou parle quand je poussais mon
doigt dedans le le muscle record
aujourd'hui vingt mille ans me renvoyer
mon monde doit donc il y avait une
certaine élasticité
c'est incroyable révélé nous un secret
vous en avez mangé du mammouth
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas osé parce que là
j'ai eu danger enfin je vous le dirai
pas ce voyage mais j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de collègues russes des vieux
collègues dont elle profession car août
que j'adorais qu'ils étaient
saint pétersbourg et lui il m'a dit par
défi j'en ai dit que j'en mange est
vraiment ne le fait pas et il m'a dit
exactement ceci c'est dégueulasse ça
sent l'ammoniac vraiment de te risque
pas à ça donc je n'ai pas donc je n'ai
pas osé manger les mains vides mais
j'aurais pu la chair était tellement
heureuse et est belle c'est quand on a
faim c'est tentant à la limite je vous
arrête quelques secondes et puis on se
retrouve dans un instant pour parler
pour peut-être de l'avenir d'ailleurs
[Musique]
bien on se retrouve sur le plateau de la
grande interview avec yves coppens
paléontologue vous êtes sans doute yves
coppens le savant grâce auquel nous
commençons
dans cette planète à savoir d'où nous
venons ça vous vient d'où cette passion
à vous quand vous étiez enfant
vous aviez déjà envie de fouiller
partout et des de poser des questions
posées des questions pas forcément mais
en tout cas un fouillé partout oui vous
êtes breton vous êtes vannes je suis né
en bretagne à nice pour ancien arrêts
oui je ne sais pas comment est venue
cette passion mais je pense que a écouté
les petits enfants aujourd'hui c'est
surtout le fait que l'imagination est
fantastique chez un enfant et on a dû un
jour attiré mon attention aux vers le
sol et ceux qui étaient enfouis dans le
sol et à partir de ce moment là mon
imagination a débordé et je né sais
c'est que je n'ai cessé d'aller fouiller
dans ce sol pour trouver les restes de
cultures passées d'animaux disparus etc
et alors le camp breton et bien sûr moi
je ne sais pas ça je n'en sais rien a
commencé est apparu mais le fait dans la
région dans laquelle j'habite est acquis
et la région de vannes carnac la trinité
sur mer etc il ya des menhirs et des
dolmens partout donc vous ne pouvez pas
faire une petite ambiance et dans les
chansons rencontrer un de ces monstres
de de pierre qui est planté pour vous ça
doit quand même faire travailler un
petit peu de l'imaginaire et vous êtes
allé très vite à la sq au 1
travailler sur un jeu sur les grottes et
travailler non mais là ce qu il se
trouve que mes parents ont bien compris
que ce thème un patient et quand lascaux
a été découvert dans la grotte de
lascaux en 1940 évidemment ça n'a pas
été ouvert tout de suite mais dès que ça
a été ouvert mes parents en effet sont
venus me accompagner et je suis dans les
polders à les premiers pollueurs de la
grotte de lascaux puisque c'est à la
suite du grand nombre de visiteurs des
premiers temps que on a dû la fermer et
mais mes parents m'ont aussi d'ailleurs
emmené altamira c'est à dire que j'ai vu
lascaux très très tôt et altamira lille
d'équivalent en espagne la grotte
étonnant d'un d'altamira également
traitement est retourné alors une
question qui nous obsède toussaint c'est
de savoir d'où on vient
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe enfin vous avez fait un bouquin
lesage l'afrique l'homme on découvre
qu'on descend pas du singe vous avez
vous avez brisé ce tabou oui non c'est
pas tout à fait vrai les primates c'est
à dire ceux qui la grande la grande
famille qui comporte à la fois les 10 à
legrand chargé les hommes apparaît
autour de 70 millions d'années 110
millions d'années et toute la longue
histoire de 70 millions d'années à 10
millions d'années ce ne sont que des
sages donc on appelle ça des primates
polissage donc dans une certaine mesure
nous désirons du renom deux singes et le
malheur c'est que quand on dit descente
des sages on a l'impression qu'on
descend des chimpanzés et pas du tout
les chimpanzés et nous sommes cousins
c'est à dire qu'on a des grands-parents
commun et il ya des millions d'années on
se sépare et les chimpanzés surdéveloppé
de leur côté nous d'une autre donc nous
ne descendons pas des chats poser certes
mais les ancêtres communs des chimpanzés
de nous-mêmes sont néanmoins des singes
supérieur sont des sages quand même leur
ma grand-mère pour vous amuser qui était
à grand mère maternelle qui était
bretonne me disais si toi tu descendais
sa joie sur 20 points
mais on a cette particularité de vivre
sur ses pattes arrière quand même un de
marcher sur ses deux pattes arrière oui
mais ça a été justement le la grande
spécificité de notre famille ça a été il
ya des millions d'années pour des
raisons d'ouverture du paysage il ya
toujours une raison de se mettre debout
alors quand je dis ça c'est pas tout à
fait vrai c'est c'est évidemment
darwinien c'est à dire que le milieu a
changé comme le milieu a changé il a
fallu s'y adapter il ya eu une série de
mutations au hasard et parmi ces
mutations au hasard y en a une qui était
le corps redresser et qui a mieux
convenu à un environnement du moment et
à partir voilà en effet on s'est mis
debout et on s'est mis debout et c'est
un changement total la tête n'est pas
posée de même manière sur la colonne
vertébrale jacquelin intégral à quelques
cours dure pour pour bien tenir droit le
bassin est un bassin en pression qui
supporte tous les organes et puis les
pattes inférieures s'allonge alors que
les membres supérieurs se réduisent on a
une rose la dure c'est le résultat d'une
évolution j'allais dire naturel quoi ah
oui absolument ah oui absolument on veut
absolument oui tout à fait le
redressement du corps d'une part et puis
l'émergence de l'homme il ya trois
millions d'années leur attention du
corps c'est 10 millions oui le l'homme
c'est 3 millions elle vote lucie
copine là elle a 3 millions et quelques
uns c'est ça je sais juste avant l homme
et lorsque l'homme apparaît il apparaît
pour toujours la même chose pour une
raison obligatoire pour la nécessité
d'une adaptation un changement
climatique mais le changement qui
retient c'est à grand coup de frein et
les grands coups de sécheresse fait
qu'il ya moins de végétaux à manger donc
il se met à manger de la viande fait qu'
il faut réfléchir un petit peu a évité
la d'or du prédateur dans un milieu très
découvert ou ce que de se faire
rattraper plus facilement et le
développement de la tête fait que la le
cerveau dépasse un certain niveau de
complexité et et va utiliser ce
dépassement de manière pirates et ça le
début de la le début de l'installation
d'un gros cerveau c'est une adaptation
et les usages que l'on en a fait ensuite
y compris de faire cette émission
aujourd'hui c'est une exhortation oui
c'est à dire qu'on a triché on a utilisé
ce développement du cerveau qui a été
fait pour autre chose
d'une manière tout à fait
le déterminant le plus fort si je vous
comprends bien c'est le climat et la pac
qui assure la végétation et les moyens
de se nourrir sur le budget et sa
végétation et sur les animaux ouais bien
sûr plus la sélection naturelle
des animaux darwinien pas plus elle
devait intervenir oui pas plus c'est la
sélection naturelle qui fait tout ça
quoi et ça fait nous le panneau des
paléontologues nous voyons ça a
posteriori donc on voit l'histoire telle
qu'elle s'est déroulée oui donc on peut
avoir l'impression que ce s'est déroulé
de manière
obligatoire alors quel est le regard que
vous portez aujourd'hui vous avec tout
ce dont tout se recula sur l'actualité
qui est dominé par leurs risques de
réchauffement climatique de la planète
oui ben c'est pas séparatistes c'est une
réalité alors le lait réchauffement
climatique ça eu lieu des millions de
fois le climat n'a cessé de changer
depuis 4 milliards 600 millions d'années
depuis une date héritèrent est donc ce
n'est pas surprenant ceci dit on à dire
à juste raison que le développement de
l'humanité le développement en
démographique de l'humanité on est passé
quand même d'un milliards à 8 milliards
en 200 ans et puis le développement
technologique et s'est fait que on n'y a
mis aussi d'une autre c'est à dire que
se développe ce changement climatique il
est un petit peu dur aussi à notre mode
de vie un autre mois de vie actuellement
absolument on est responsable de ça pas
de pas tout mais on est responsable
sûrement d'une partie et le travail que
l'on fait en ce moment les efforts que
l'on fait en ce moment c'est pour
réduire cette partie là qui nous revient
mais autrement un changement climatique
c'est normal alors je sais ce que je
voulais vous raconter c'est que au mit à
cette date un peu importe à ruminer pack
géologiques il ya 15 millions d'années
il ya eu ce même réchauffement
climatique la même chose ici dans le sud
de l'europe et sur les changements
climatiques fait que les singes qui
étaient en afrique sont aussi passés en
europe il y en avait en turquie ça
s'appelle d'ankara pittacus y en avait
en grèce s'appelle le greco pitt et q si
on avait en
italie en france c'était le trio petit
écusson et spa etc et aujourd'hui comme
ce climat redevient chaud cet amusant de
penser que la faune africaine va
peut-être un peu débarquer aussi sur
notre territoire et c'est amusant de
penser que alors que l'homme est né sous
les tropiques et que pour cette raison
ils étaient colorés parce qu'il faut une
couche de mélanine pour résister à
certains ensoleillement il se décolorer
en montant vers le nord
et comme la température est en train de
monter peut-être qu'on va se colorer à
nouveau ça c'est oui parce que votre
thèse c'est de dire il n'y a pas de
noirs ya pas de blanc les blancs sont
des sondés noir décolorés vous avez dit
pas si oui c'est ça que je dis parce que
c'est quand même assez transgressive
dont le dans le climat c'est le sens de
l'histoire oui on est né colorés pour
des raisons de de synthèse de la
vitamine d epuis de résistance à
certains rayonnement du soleil et puis
petit à petit on a perdu ses couleurs
parce que l'ensoleillement était moindre
et qu'il fallait pour la croissance de
la synthèse de la vitamine d se fasse et
aujourd'hui comme la chaleur revient ne
peut être après tout que on va reprendre
une couche de 2010 dont ça se bronzer à
nouveau pour s'adapter aux
nouveau climat 38 alors j'entends bien
le rôle de
l'évolution au climat et cetera mais
l'homme l'intelligence de l'homme depuis
deux ou trois siècles a fait qu'on a
fait des découvertes extraordinaires qui
permettent de résister à l'évolution
naturelle toutes les innovations
technologiques
le moteur à explosion
l'électricité et puis aujourd'hui le
digital pour cette capacité qu'ont à
deux ça doit aller allant à l'encontre
d'une femme à corriger certaines choses
non il y a il ya la fois le
développement naturel qui se poursuit un
oui on a l'impression venu au corps
comme ça sont inertes mais ça se
poursuit à bas bruit tout simplement
parce que le développement culturel que
vous venez de décrire et plus rapide
donc oui les plus tant qu'il est plus
rapide c'est le développement naturel
est un peu enfin il paraît ce à quoi
disons mais regardez l'histoire de deux
virus actuel on a trouvé oui on a trouvé
le moyen de le contrer avec un vaccin et
c'est fort bien ainsi imaginez qu'on ne
trouve pas le moyen le donc la culture à
ce moment-là disparaît puisqu'elle n'a
pas réussi à faire face à cette épreuve
et c'est le développement naturel qui
revient c'est à dire qu' une partie de
l'humanité disparaît et puis l'autre
résister résister parce que elle
continué à se transformer parce qu'il ya
des des mutations du genre humain qui
font que certaines mutations sont
meilleurs que d'autres puis on change
d'espèces produits rage sur sa pierre en
vous en vous écoutant je ne résiste pas
à la tentation de vous demander quel est
votre regard que vous portez aujourd'hui
sur la théorie du genre par exemple oui
voilà le genre enfin le l'histoire du du
ni folle il n'y a pas d'eau n'y a pas de
femmes il ya un genre humain oui ah oui
ça c'est autre jour quand on dit genre
sommes humains le genre homo à chaud les
mots et puis l'espèce humaine ce sont
deux classifications zoologie c'est
autre chose mais le genre mâle femelle
ça date un peu plus d'un milliard
d'années c'est à dire que la
reproduction sexuée date de plus d'un
milliard d'années au lieu d'avoir une
révolution ali à l'identique ya toujours
des erreurs à l'identique oui comme le
viol par exemple la reproduction à ce
moment là et est faite par deux
personnages et du coup on peut dire que
qui fait un oeuf fait du neuf c'est
important dans la production c'était un
oeuf est dit c'est joli vrai c'était une
belle phrase merci et en l'occurrence
elle c'est le but de la reproduction
sexuée alors ceci dit que dans une
société il y est d'aider des personnes
des personnes masculine sur le plan de
du corps et qui les tendances plus
féminine que d'autres haute tension on a
les deux airbags en soi même donc il est
normal qu'ils aient toute une gamme de
gens qui sont tantôt intentons l'autre
ou ou intermédiaire quelque sorte ou
plutôt l'un plutôt l'autre ou un peu
plus l'un que l'autre c'est pas c'est
pas surprenant et c'est un peu la
théorie du genre cette de long dont on
parle aujourd'hui et qui est tout à fait
respectable
on a encore beaucoup de choses à
découvrir c'est vrai oui vous avez
encore plein de curiosité que vous mais
alors on n'a pas découvert grand chose
on n'a pas des gouvernements des justes
aux débuts de nez à la mécanique du
cerveau sur nos idées peut par exemple
ça ça progresse à ses progrès oui la
microstructure de un micro structures du
lancer fable apporte des idées
aujourd'hui même sur la naissance
probablement du sens religieuse qui est
extraordinaire
merci beaucoup j'avais envie de
conseiller deux ou trois livia ya un
lien d origine de les origines de
l'homme 1 c'est bien de savants le
fossile et le prince que vous avez fait
aussi origines de l'homme origines
d'anor bon je rappelle quand même le
livre un des livres les plus célèbres
sais c'est le genou de l'uci c'est quoi
ça c'est vous avez appelé commune
pourquoi le genou de lucie
cvc sérique romer qui va que vous a
donné ce nom là avec son genou de claire
ou lucie cdu chansons des beatles
absolument 1 absolument en fait l'année
d'abord l'uci
1973 on avait déjà trouvé un morceau de
fémur et un morceau de tibias c'est à
dire à genoux que j'avais appelé le
genou de claire ah oui mais quand vous
aviez genou de claire
74 on trouve d'autres genou cette voie
là de l'uci et puis d'autres jospin donc
si j'ai appelé le sait de lui si c'est
simplement parce que j'avais donnés en
thèse à une jeune femme de mon
laboratoire l'étude du genou et elle
s'est aperçue que le lucie hotte est
debout incontestablement jusqu'au
jusqu'aux genoux mais à partir des
genoux ça n'a plus la même chose ça
indiqué au contraire là le l'aptitude à
grimper donc le lucie était de boue
jusqu'aux genoux et du genou au pied
allait-elle grimpeuse quoi elle était
plus sage que qu'humala en termine sur
cette image rurale
jeu claires là le genou de celui-ci
merci beaucoup yves coppens merci ce fut
un grand plaisir pour nous tous on
retrouve les missions évidemment replay
sur la chaîne on la retrouve sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis sur le site
internet aussi arte france pointe et vf
copains mille merci merci à très bientôt
[Musique]